كسوف بؤره صراع لا ينتهي في البلقان
فالسرب الارثوذكس الذين سيطروا على
الاقليم في القرن الثاني عشر الميلادي
يعتبرون الكسوف قلب امتهم والالبان
واغلبهم مسلمون يعتبرونه ارضهم التاريخيه
كان انتصار العثمانيين في معركه كسوف في
القرن الرابع عشر نقطه تحول في تاريخ
الاقليم خصوصا ان اغلب الالباني اعتنقل
الاسلام دام حكم العثمانيين 500 عام ترسخت
خلاله ملامح قوميه البانيه مسلمه مقابله
للقوميه الصربيه
وفي بدايه القرن العشرين استعادت صربيا
سيطره على كسوسه وبعد تاسيسه غزلان خلال
المد الشيوعي اصبح اقليم وقصه جزء منها
فانها رئيس الغزال الحكم الذاتي في
الاقليم عامه 90 لكنه غزلان يتفككت بعد
عام من ذلك ليبدا صراع جديد من اجل
الاستقلال عن
شهدت سنوات التسعينيات صراعا دمويا بين
الصرب والالبان في كوسوفو وكانت صربيا
سندا للصرف الاقليم والتهمت بارتكاب مجازر
بحق الالبان وبعد عده تحذيرات شنحلف
الناتو غارات جويه عامه 99 ارغمت صربيا
على سحب قواتها لتبدا مرحله اشراف الامم
المتحده على الاقليم في عام 2008 اعلن
كسوف واستقلاله من جانب واحد اعتبرت صربيا
كما كان متوقعا الاعلان غير قانوني في
المقابل اعترفت الولايات المتحده والدور
الاوروبيه الكبرى باستقلال الكسوف بقيه
كسوسه من عام 2008 حتى عام 2012 تحت اداره
دوليه شاركت فيها الولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه وتركيا وفي عام 2013 توصلت
حكومه كسوه والصربيا الى اتفاق لتطبيعه
العلاقات مع منح سر كسوه في الشمال واسعا
من الحكم الذاتي
كان واضحا ان ما حفظ الطرفين وخصوص صربيا
على توقيع الاتفاق هو الرغبه في الانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكن الخلافات الكامنه لم
تنتهي لان صربيا مازالت تعتبر كسبه جزءا
من ارضها ولان الصرب في شمال كسبه يحسون
بالانتماء لصربيا اكثر من احساسهم
بالانتماء لكسبه